[موسيقى]
واحده من العناصر
اللي اسهمت بشكل مباشر في تعقيد
سرديه الهويه ان شئت تجارب الاستعمار
المتعدده والمتنوعه التي خضعت لها هذه
الجغرافيا بحدودها اللي هي اصلا رسمها
الاستعمار من الاستعمار يعود الى ما قبل
الميلاد طبعا عرفت الممالك النوبيه
القديمه خدعت لاستعمار الفراعنه يعني
الاسر المعروفه في التاريخ
بالاضافه الى
الجغرافيا السودان وحتى هذه اللحظه هي
كانت
ندبه حقيقيه ليش لانه هو في الوسط ومفتوح
على عدد هائل من يعني
المجاوره يعني عرفت
[موسيقى]
في واحد اللي هو كرومر اللورد كرومر معروف
هو كان مهندس الاستعمار البريطاني او
الكولونياليه البريطانيه
هذا الرجل لما راى من من حضور البنيه
الاثنيه وشاف الاشتباكات والنزاعات
القبليه من من من من فجر التاريخ
قال وصيه الوحيده هذا في كتابه معروف اسمه
مصر الحديثه عرفت في بضعه مجلدات وكان
نصيب السودان منها كبير يعني اللورد كرومر
قال مما شاهدته
ينبغي على اهل هذه البلد ان يفكروا في
حكومه حقيقيه وليست قوميه او وطني
[موسيقى]
تجارب الخضع عليها السودان
كانت متنوعه متعدده اسهمت يا استاذ مشاري
بشكل مباشر في انقطاعات مد قومي
وعلى فكره انا لم اقل هذا الكلام قاله
المفكر الاقتصادي الراحل سميره مين قال
انه السودان والجزائر في المحيط العربي
والافريقي بالتحديد يعني اسوا ما خلفه
الاستعمار ان شئت انه عمل الاستعمار بشكل
مباشر وبشكل غير مباشر حتى كمان على قطع
المد القومي والوطني
وهذه مره مهمه يعني لا تتصور انه
مالات هذا الامر نعاني منها حتى هذه
اللحظه
[موسيقى]